good morning believe nation today's
message is be true to you over to you
Jamie yeah good job my advice is just do
things that are true to you you know you
know most things that I'm involved with
our extension of being creative you know
Rockaways a clothing company you know
it's part of who you are and hip-hop is
your attitude and what you're trying to
express express how you dress um you
know I love sports growing up I grew up
in a household where sports was on 24
you know seven so these are things that
are you know are comfortable for me you
know these are things that I like so I
would just say get involved in things
that you love and also have you know
have a standard for yourself and have
some sort of integrity and try to you
know find some sort of truth in what
you're doing this is a really important
message for entrepreneurs because often
we do things because of other people we
take the job that our parents want us to
take or we submit depressions that our
friends put upon us but if you really
want to do something great you really
want to have a big impact really want to
be happy with your life then you have to
do things that are true to you even if
that means buck in the common advice
[ __ ] the common trends bucking the
wisdom that other people are trying to
give to you and those people are often
giving you messages out of love they
want to see you successful they want to
see you going and and create a life that
you're happy with but they're also
limited in their views and the only real
advice you should take is the one that
you feel is really true
to you so my question the day for you
today is I want to know what kind of
advice that you turn down advice that
that made sense from another person's
perspective things that your parents
told you your friends told you that you
should do but you just couldn't take it
because it wasn't true to you leave it
in the comments below I'm really curious
to see what they said thank you so much
for watching continue to believe and
i'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot a vinspresso